Pardon pour l’interruption, mais j’ai
une question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
Nous sommes en 1910.
Keynes, l’homme qui va révolutionner la
théorie économique, a déjà 27 ans.
Il part en en Grèce avec son amant.
Le souci, c’est qu’il a le mal de mer.
Il passe donc le voyage aller allongé dans
leur cabine.
Comment est-ce qu’il tue le temps ?
En lisant la moitié de La Richesse des nations
d’Adam Smith.
Ce gros livre indigeste est la première pierre
de la théorie économique moderne, ce qui
fait d’Adam Smith le « père » de la théorie
économique.
L’amant de Keynes le voit plongé dans son
énorme bouquin.
Il lui demande ce qu’il en pense.
« C’est un livre magnifique », lui répond
Keynes.
Si vous vous êtes intéressés même grossièrement
à l’économie, alors vous savez probablement
qu’il y a deux grands noms : ADAM SMITH,
et JOHN MAYNARD KEYNES.
Et pour faire simple, ces deux penseurs sont
les pères des deux grandes visions de l’économie,
la vision libérale classique, et la vision
dite « keynésienne ».
En présentant les choses comme ça, Smith
et Keynes apparaissent comme des rivaux.
Mais en réalité, l’influence de Keynes
est bien supérieure.
C’est lui qui a imaginé la manière dont
la société occidentale du XXIe siècle fonctionne
parce que c’est lui qui a imaginé les solutions
que les dirigeants ont choisies pour régler
les problèmes économiques du XXe siècle.
C’est aussi lui qui a imaginé la manière
dont la société occidentale du XXIe siècle
se comprend
parce que c’est lui qui a fait de l’économie
une des disciplines intellectuelles de référence,
sinon LA discipline intellectuelle de référence
pour comprendre le monde.
Et contrairement à Adam Smith, Keynes n’a
pas mené une vie qui rend difficile de trouver
10 anecdotes révélatrices.
Même si j’avais voulu raconter 30 anecdotes,
j’aurais dû en jeter un paquet.
Les 10 que j’ai choisies, c’est donc la
crême de la crême des deux biographies que
j’ai lues.
J’ai juste un peu peur que les dernières
anecdotes vous énervent.
Voici un extrait du journal intime du père
de Keynes (qui a alors 17 ans) :
« Sous ma direction, Maynard travaille régulièrement
trois heures par jour. Je me fais l’effet
d’un entraîneur ; comme si je l’entraînais
pour une course ou un grand prix ».
Autrement dit, le père fait office de prof
particulier, 3 heures par jour.
Pourquoi est-ce qu’il s’implique autant
?
Parce que son fils va bientôt passer des
examens qui lui permettront, s’il les réussit,
de décrocher une bourse pour intégrer la
prestigieuse université britannique de Cambridge.
Cette anecdote montre que l’excellence académique
et intellectuelle de Keynes est le fruit d’une
intense stimulation parentale.
Le père de Keynes ne s’est pas réveillé
lorsque son fils a eu 17 ans
— il l’a stimulé depuis sa plus tendre
enfance,
en éveillant sa curiosité, en lui apprenant
beaucoup de choses, et en lui transmettant
le goût de la lecture.
Et comme les parents n’ont pas les moyens
d’envoyer l’adolescent Keynes dans les
plus prestigieuses institutions académiques
anglaises, ils misent sur les bourses.
Première étape : il faut que Keynes décroche
une bourse pour Eton.
Eton, c’est LE lycée de l’élite anglaise.
On retrouve notamment ses élèves aux plus
hauts échelons de l’administration britannique,
si bien qu’environ un tiers des premiers
ministres anglais sont passés par Eton.
Les parents de Keynes engagent des profs particuliers
pour préparer l’examen d’entrée.
Ça paie : à 14 ans, Keynes entre à Eton
avec une bourse.
Seconde étape 3 ans plus tard : décrocher
une bourse pour Cambridge.
Cette fois-ci, c’est son père qui est son
« entraîneur », d’après ses propres
mots.
Mais pourquoi est-ce que son père veut LUI-MÊME
préparer son fils pour les examens d’entrée
à l’université de Cambridge ?
Parce qu’il est lui-même prof à Cambridge
!
Et prof de quoi ?
Vous me voyez venir : prof d’économie.
Et pas n’importe quel prof d’économie
: il a écrit un manuel qui fait autorité.
Mais un économiste du tournant du XXe siècle,
ce n’est pas comme un économiste de 2023.
Le père de Keynes n’est pas un spécialiste.
Il a une large culture générale ; et il
est aussi philosophe, mathématicien et logicien.
Je ne dis pas tout cela pour crier à l’injustice
ou nier le mérite de Keynes.
Je rappelle simplement la vérité dont la
pensée occidentale a, au XIXe siècle, reconnu
l’importance cruciale : c’est le milieu
qui fait l’homme.
Oui, Keynes est un véritable génie.
Mais économiste très cultivé formé à
Cambridge, il est le fils… d’un économiste
très cultivé formé à Cambridge.
Et sa mère ?
Elle est diplômée… de Cambridge.
Nous sommes début 1919.
Ludwig Wittgenstein, un des plus grands philosophes
de la logique du XXe siècle — Wittgenstein
est prisonnier en Italie.
Il servait dans l'armée austro-hongroise,
qui a perdu la guerre.
Et là, début 1919, il est retenu dans un
camp en Italie.
Il a avec lui le manuscrit qu’il a écrit
pendant la guerre — et il a peur de le perdre.
Bertrand Russell, un des philosophes les plus
influents du XXe siècle, et l’auteur de
l’histoire de référence de la philosophie
occidentale
— Bertrand Russell se soucie du sort de
Wittgenstein dans la prison italienne parce
qu’ils ont travaillé ensemble à Cambridge
et qu’ils continuent d’échanger.
Or, Bertrand Russell est aussi un ami proche
de Keynes.
Comme il sait que Keynes a un bon réseau
dans l’administration anglaise, il lui demande
d’utiliser ses relations pour aider Wittgenstein.
Alors Keynes fait pression sur le gouvernement
anglais afin que le manuscrit de Wittgenstein
lui soit envoyé à lui, Keynes, avec une
expédition sécurisée.
Il le reçoit ; puis il l’envoie à Bertrand
Russell.
C’est à l’influence politique de Keynes
que nous devons la publication du Tractatus
logico-philosophicus de Wittgenstein, un des
chefs-d’œuvre de la philosophie du XXe
siècle.
Cette anecdote révèle la dualité de Keynes.
En tant qu’économiste de haut niveau, il
fréquente la haute administration, la finance
et le monde des affaires
— mais il a également un pied dans l’élite
culturelle.
Et cela, il le doit notamment à son appartenance
au « groupe de Bloomsbury ».
Le nom « groupe de Bloomsbury » vient du
quartier de Bloomsbury, au centre de Londres,
où se tiennent les réunions.
Les membres du groupe sont des artistes et
intellectuels anticonformistes, la plupart
formés à Cambridge.
Parmi eux, il y a Virginia Woolf, une des
plus célèbres romancières du XXe siècle.
À travers le groupe de Bloomsbury, Keynes
est en contact avec l’élite culturelle
occidentale de l’époque : peintres français,
philosophes allemands, romanciers russes,
etc.
Et ce milieu social très spécial lui inspire
sa vision personnelle du bonheur.
Contrairement à beaucoup d’économistes,
Keynes ne pense pas que l’homme moderne
sera heureux en consommant plus de biens et
de services.
Ce qu’il imagine, lui, c’est que les gens
seront heureux lorsqu’ils auront assez de
temps libre à consacrer à la contemplation
et à la création d’œuvres d’art.
Les droits d’auteur représentent en général
une petite fraction du prix d’un livre,
autour de 10 % (même si ça varie selon les
situations).
Si c’est assez faible, c’est parce que
c’est L’ÉDITEUR qui prend le risque économique
:
c’est lui qui finance l’impression du
premier stock d’exemplaires, sans savoir
s’ils se vendront.
Mais si c’est L’AUTEUR qui paie lui-même
l’impression, alors il peut tirer un revenu
bien plus conséquent des ventes de son livre.
C’est pour ça qu’aujourd’hui, des auteurs
gagnent très bien leur vie en s’autoéditant
sur Amazon :
ils gagnent 3, 4, voire 5 fois plus qu’avec
un éditeur traditionnel.
L’impression à la demande n’existe pas
à l’époque de Keynes, mais il a les moyens
de payer de sa poche l’impression d’un
premier stock.
C’est le choix qu’il fait en 1919.
Comme des tracas administratifs ralentissent
la publication de son livre, Keynes décide
de prendre les choses en main.
En finançant l’impression, il devient le
maître du projet.
Son éditeur, la prestigieuse maison d’édition
Macmillan, est réduite à un rôle de distributeur.
Le rapport de forces est inversé :
c’est Keynes qui décide, et c’est l’éditeur
qui devra se contenter de 10 % du prix du
livre.
Il ne regrettera pas sa décision.
Son livre, Les Conséquences économiques
de la paix, est le plus célèbre pamphlet
économique de l’histoire.
Il se vend comme des petits pains, et donc
Keynes gagne beaucoup d’argent.
Mais il peste parce qu’il ne touche que
15 % des ventes à l’étranger.
Or, c’est aux États-Unis que les ventes
explosent.
Pourquoi est-ce que le livre marche si bien
?
Parce qu’il crée le scandale.
Les belligérants de la Première Guerre mondiale
viennent de signer le traité de Versailles,
donc les vainqueurs « vendent » (entre guillemets)
le traité à l’opinion.
Les populations ont tellement souffert pendant
la guerre, maintenant il faut qu’elles pensent
que ça se termine bien.
Le président américain Wilson, architecte
majeur du traité avec ses quatorze points,
reçoit le Prix Nobel de la paix juste après.
Mais le pamphlet de Keynes sort 2 jours plus
tard.
Il démontre clairement, chiffres à l’appui,
que le traité de Versailles va appauvrir
les peuples de l’Europe.
Prophète, il suggère que les réparations
écrasantes imposées à l’Allemagne vont
engendrer des troubles politiques et de nouvelles
tensions en Europe.
Et si le diagnostic de Keynes est très convainquant,
c’est parce qu’il a lui-même participé
aux négociations qui ont abouti au traité
de Versailles
(c’est d’ailleurs cette position qui lui
a permis de sauver le manuscrit de Wittgenstein
!).
Il critique donc le traité de Versailles
avec la légitimité d’un acteur de premier
plan.
En plus de montrer que le traité est une
mauvaise solution, il se moque des dirigeants
politiques.
Il compare par exemple le président américain
Wilson à Don Quichotte, c’est-à-dire un
idéaliste fou ;
et il dit que Georges Clemenceau, le représentant
de la France, est un vieillard qui voit le
monde avec de vieilles lunettes.
Au début de la Première Guerre mondiale,
les investissements financiers de Keynes valent
environ 5 000 livres sterling
(l’équivalent de 500 000 dollars d’aujourd’hui).
À la fin de la guerre, ils valent 15 000
livres.
Fois trois en 4 ans : super !
C’est tellement rapide que c’est suspect.
Parce que Keynes ne se contente pas de lire
le Financial Times pendant la guerre.
Non, il travaille au niveau le plus élevé
de l’administration économique britannique.
Il joue un rôle clé dans les questions financières
liées à la guerre.
Autrement dit, il a accès aux secrets économiques
du gouvernement en même temps qu’il spécule
sur des valeurs liées aux décisions du gouvernement.
C’est pas un conflit d’intérêt, ça
?
À l’époque, ça passait — mais aujourd’hui,
ça créerait un énorme scandale.
Apparemment, Keynes n’a jamais fait des
recommandations pour favoriser ses propres
investissements,
mais il a bien évidemment utilisé les secrets
auxquels il avait accès pour faire fructifier
son capital, ce qui viole le principe fondamental
d’égal accès à l’information.
Autrement dit, Keynes commet au cours de la
Première Guerre mondiale ce qu’on appelle
des « délits d’initié ».
Cette anecdote montre qu’il était un spéculateur.
Il commence à spéculer en bourse au début
de la vingtaine.
Sa compréhension des mécanismes économiques
lui permet de monter en 5 ans à plus de 500
livres sterling
(l’équivalent de 50 000 dollars d’aujourd’hui).
Il continue, et au début de la Première
Guerre mondiale, il a multiplié son capital
par 9.
La série de succès continue après la guerre
:
il obtient des gains rapides en spéculant
sur les monnaies.
Donc Keynes est vraiment un investisseur doué.
Sa réputation d’investisseur grandit, au
point que les gens lui demandent d’investir
leur argent :
la famille, les amis, et même l’université
de Cambridge !
Keynes crée alors un fonds d’investissement.
Au début de 1920, il mise sur un renchérissement
du dollar par rapport aux monnaies européennes.
Et pas de chance, c’est l’inverse qui
se produit.
Keynes perd plus de 22 000 livres sterling,
l’équivalent de millions de dollars d’aujourd’hui.
Eh oui, même les hommes les plus intelligents
ne peuvent pas prévoir l’avenir avec certitude.
Mais Keynes a les moyens de réduire l’incertitude
des marchés.
Il interroge ses contacts politiques pour
prévoir la tendance des devises ;
il obtient un prêt de 5 000 livres ;
et en moins de 2 ans, son fonds et lui-même
sont revenus dans le vert.
Deux ans plus tard, en 1924, il est lui-même
multimillionnaire en dollars d’aujourd’hui
(sa fortune personnelle s’élève à entre
5 et 10 millions de dollars).
Donc Keynes est devenu très riche par la
spéculation.
Si vous connaissez un peu sa théorie économique,
ça doit vous étonner.
En effet, il dit que la spéculation est un
facteur majeur d’instabilité pour l’économie.
Il compare même le fonctionnement des marchés
boursiers à un casino.
Si vous voulez voyager en Russie aujourd’hui,
c’est compliqué — mais c’est possible.
Le plus chiant, c’est que vous ne pourrez
pas utiliser vos cartes bancaires.
Donc il faudra vous trimbaler avec des liasses
de billets.
Moi, c’est ce qui me retient d’aller faire
un tour à Saint-Pétersbourg, alors que c’est
l’histoire de quelques heures en voiture.
Maintenant, imaginez voyager en Russie en
1925, 7 ans après la révolution !
Non seulement vous ne pouvez pas commander
un visa sur internet,
mais surtout les problèmes pratiques sont
bien plus lourds que l’invalidité des cartes
bancaires !
Et pourtant, Keynes se rend à Moscou. Il
a été invité à une conférence.
Pourquoi donc prend-il ce risque ?
Parce qu’il vient de se marier avec une
femme russe !
À 42 ans, il épouse la célèbre ballerine
Lydia Lopokova, qui a elle 33 ans.
Ils vont célébrer leur mariage avec la famille
russe à Saint-Pétersbourg
(qui s’appelle à l’époque « Leningrad
», c’est-à-dire « ville de Lénine »).
Que Keynes se marie est étonnant, parce qu’il
a toujours été homosexuel.
C’est d’autant plus étonnant qu’il
a toujours mené sa vie romantique avec une
grande liberté (surtout pour l’époque).
Mais un soir d’hiver 1921, il voit Lydia
Lopokova danser dans une adaptation de La
Belle au bois dormant de Tchaïkovski
— et il tombe amoureux.
En plus d’être belle, la ballerine est
célèbre.
Sa troupe vend même des « poupées Lydia
» aux foules qui remplissent les salles.
Keynes réserve les places les plus proches
de la scène, qui sont les plus chères.
Il va la voir en coulisses et l’invite à
déjeuner.
Ils sont mutuellement envoûtés :
elle par l’exceptionnelle intelligence de
Keynes, lui par l’énergie et le talent
de Lydia.
Quelques années plus tard, ils forment un
couple célèbre.
Lydia, qui a été élevée dans le respect
des intellectuels, admire la célébrité
et l’autorité de Keynes.
Mais tout n’est pas rose.
Au début, Keynes a toujours des aventures
homosexuelles,
et il faut que Lydia le supplie pour qu’il
accepte de lui être fidèle.
Autre souci : les amis de Bloomsbury sont
réticents à intégrer Lydia, qui n’a pas
exactement leur mentalité ni leur aisance
intellectuelle.
Elle devra attendre longtemps avant d’être
pleinement acceptée dans le groupe.
Enfin, pour des raisons non élucidées, le
couple n'a pas eu d'enfants.
Nous sommes au début de 1932.
Keynes, qui est prof à Cambridge, se rend
chez son assistant Richard Kahn.
Dans son excitation intellectuelle, il entre
sans prévenir, comme il a l’habitude de
faire.
Et là, il tombe sur une scène embarrassante
:
son assistant Richard Kahn est allongé sur
le sol sur des coussins avec Joan Robinson,
elle aussi assistante de Keynes.
Le souci, c’est que Joan Robinson est mariée
à Austin Robinson… lui aussi assistant
de Keynes.
Je résume : une assistante de Keynes trompe
un assistant de Keynes avec un assistant de
Keynes.
Keynes décide de ne rien faire — mais il
est bien embêté par cette affaire.
Pourtant, il est loin d’être un puritain.
Alors pourquoi est-ce que cette affaire lui
prend la tête ?
Parce qu’elle trouble le travail de ses
assistants, qui est vraiment précieux pour
lui.
En fait, le terme « assistant » est un euphémisme
qui minimise leur rôle réel.
Cette anecdote révèle que Keynes est en
réalité le chef d’une équipe intellectuelle,
ce qu’on appelle le « cercle de Cambridge
» (« Cambridge Circus » en anglais).
De la même manière que nous croyons spontanément
qu’un chef politique prend ses décisions
seul et qu’il impose sa volonté au pays
entier,
nous croyons que les grands penseurs travaillent
seul et que leurs idées s’imposent d’elles-mêmes
dans l’opinion.
Mais c’est souvent une illusion.
En tout cas, ça l’est évidemment avec
Keynes.
S’il réussit à révolutionner l’économie
et à marquer la pensée occidentale avec
son chef-d’œuvre,
la Théorie générale de l'emploi, de l'intérêt
et de la monnaie, c’est grâce aux brillants
esprits qui l’ont aidé dans l’ombre.
Non seulement il a pu leur soumettre ses idées
et les leur faire corriger, mais ses assistants
lui ont également fourni des idées cruciales.
Joan Robinson, par exemple, montre que le
laisser-faire est une illusion.
L’économie réelle ne correspond pas du
tout à ce que décrivent les manuels classiques.
En réalité, la prospérité est un résultat
POLITIQUE.
L’influence intellectuelle de cette géniale
femme économiste est telle que certains historiens
de l’économie estiment que la thèse de
base de la Théorie générale de Keynes était
en réalité déjà présente dans des articles
de Joan Robinson publiés avant.
Et l’autre « assistant » avec lequel elle
trompe son mari, Richard Kahn,
n’est nul autre que l’auteur du concept
crucial du multiplicateur, grâce auquel Keynes
justifie l’intervention de l’État dans
l’économie.
Lorsque l’État dépense 1 euro, il enclenche
un cercle vertueux de création de valeur,
ce qui transforme l’euro initial en 1,5,
2, voire 3 4 euros.
Nous sommes au cours de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale.
L’Allemagne mène des campagnes de bombardement
contre le Royaume-Uni.
À Cambridge, Keynes est parfois affecté
à une mission de surveillance des incendies
au sommet de la chapelle gothique médiévale.
Armés de pelles, son coéquipier et lui doivent
repousser toute bombe incendiaire allemande
égarée sur le toit, au cas où l'une d'elles
n'exploserait pas lors d'un raid aérien.
Et un jour, son coéquipier est… Friedrich
Hayek.
Oui, Hayek, l’ennemi idéologique de Keynes.
Hayek, le défenseur du marché, l’économiste
qui voit ce que recommande Keynes, l’intervention
de l’État, comme un danger.
Qu’est-ce que Hayek fait à Cambridge ?
Eh bien, la London School of Economics où
enseigne Hayek a été délocalisée à Cambridge
pour des raisons de sécurité.
Les deux grands économistes se croisent donc
au quotidien pendant plusieurs années.
Et leur guerre idéologique ne les empêche
pas d’avoir des rapports cordiaux.
Cependant, le conflit était plus intense
au tournant des années 1930.
Les idées de Keynes commencent à se diffuser
grâce à ses premiers livres et aux articles
de ses partisans.
Hayek, qui comprend que ces idées remettent
en cause les principes fondamentaux du libéralisme
— Hayek est leur plus féroce adversaire.
Mais le conflit n’est pas simplement intellectuel.
Il faut convertir les étudiants en économie,
qui hésitent entre les deux grandes orientations
idéologiques.
Et à ce jeu, les keynésiens sont les meilleurs.
En particulier, Joan Robinson, la géniale
assistante de Keynes
— Joan Robinson réussit à faire migrer
des étudiants de la London School of Economics
à Cambridge, où ils pourront se former avec
les keynésiens.
La différence entre Keynes et Hayek, c’est
que Keynes est très charismatique.
Il est presque un chef de secte.
Lorsqu’ils sont tous les deux à Cambridge
pendant la guerre, Keynes ne se sent pas menacé
par Hayek.
Il pense avoir gagné la guerre des idées.
Mais Hayek reprend du poil de la bête en
1944, grâce au succès de son chef-d’œuvre,
La route de la servitude.
Nous sommes en janvier 1923.
Keynes assemble un consortium d’investisseurs
et rachète la majorité des parts du journal
britannique The Nation and Athenaeum
(à ne pas confondre avec le magazine américain
The Nation).
Keynes se nomme lui-même président du conseil
d’administration du journal, puis pousse
le rédacteur en chef à partir.
Pourquoi devenir propriétaire d’un magazine
?
Cela fait plusieurs années que Keynes écrit
pour le Manchester Guardian et il se rend
compte de l’influence que lui donnent ses
articles.
Il est lu dans le monde de la finance, des
affaires, de l’administration et de la politique.
Bref, les décideurs sont sensibles à ses
idées.
Il se dit qu’en étant le chef d’un journal,
il pourra décupler son audience.
Cette anecdote montre que Keynes a été un
intellectuel AVANT d’être un théoricien.
Tout du moins, il a été RECONNU comme intellectuel
avant de l’être comme théoricien.
Dans les années 1920, sa stratégie consiste
à faire gagner ses idées dans l’élite
économique et politique.
Un journal, c’est le bon instrument pour
cela.
Et comme il est un ami en or, Keynes se sert
aussi de The Nation pour soutenir tout le
groupe de Bloomsbury.
Il offre à ses amis une plateforme pour leurs
idées et contribue par là à leur future
renommée et fortune.
En moins d’un an, Keynes est l’intellectuel
le plus influent de la gauche britannique.
Tous les hommes politiques veulent son soutien
lors des élections.
Seulement, la stratégie de Keynes échoue
à convertir les dirigeants.
Ils connaissent ses idées, mais ils font
confiance aux experts, aux conseillers économiques
qui s’expriment avec du jargon et des formules
mathématiques
— tandis que Keynes est un intellectuel
qui parle au grand public, presque un vulgarisateur.
Il change donc de stratégie dans les années
1930.
Pour convertir les dirigeants, il faut convertir
leurs conseillers.
Il faut que les conseillers économiques deviennent
keynésiens.
Quand j’étais étudiant, j’ai longtemps
buggé sur le même problème.
En histoire, on nous apprend — en simplifiant
— que le président Roosevelt sort les États-Unis
de la crise de 29 grâce au New Deal.
Et on nous dit c’est une politique de relance
de l’économie inspirée par la théorie
de Keynes.
Or, le New Deal, la mise en pratique, commence
en 1933, tandis que la Théorie générale
de Keynes, la théorie, est publiée en 1936.
Comment expliquer que la théorie soit appliquée
AVANT d’être publiée ?
Eh bien, en fait, Keynes n’a pas attendu
1936 pour proposer sa solution à la crise
de 29.
L’année même de la crise, il écrit un
essai intitulé Est-ce que Lloyd George peut
le faire ?, dans lequel il examine les propositions
du candidat Lloyd George pour réduire le
chômage.
Il y défend un ambitieux programme de travaux
publics.
Et c’est CE PROGRAMME qui inspirera le New
Deal du président Roosevelt.
En fait, les États-Unis sont le laboratoire
des idées de Keynes.
Ça commence avec ce qu’on appelle le Brain
Trust, le groupe de conseillers de Roosevelt
qui ont joué un rôle crucial dans la formulation
du New Deal.
Puis les idées de Keynes pénètrent le monde
académique américain, tout particulièrement
à Harvard.
Cela, en retour, les renforce dans l’administration
américaine.
Leur influence perdure jusqu’aux années
1970.
Les dernières figures emblématiques du keynésianisme
aux États-Unis sont le président John Fitzgerald
Kennedy et son conseiller économique John
Kenneth Galbraith.
Galbraith — qui est un peu le Keynes américain
(à la différence qu’il n’a pas écrit
de chef-d’œuvre théorique en économie)
— Galbraith a été le prof d’économie
de Kennedy à Harvard.
Donc quand Kennedy veut s’entourer de brillants
intellectuels pour compenser son image de
jeune beau gosse inexpérimenté — il pense
à son professeur.
À la fin des années 1960, le keynésianisme
a gagné aux États-Unis.
C’est l’idéologie économique des profs
d’université comme des technocrates.
Lorsqu’une discipline intellectuelle devient
une discipline académique, les profs et les
élèves ont besoin d’un livre qui fournisse
une vue d’ensemble en synthétisant tout
le savoir de la discipline.
C’est ça, un manuel.
Et bien souvent, UN SEUL manuel s’impose
comme la référence.
Pour l’auteur, c’est le jackpot :
des générations d’étudiants, ou même
de curieux qui veulent découvrir la discipline
— bref des masses de lecteurs achètent
le manuel année après année, en général
pendant des décennies.
Ça représente donc une grosse rente…
…jusqu’à ce qu’un changement de paradigme
— pour parler comme Thomas Kuhn — intervienne
dans la discipline.
On a alors besoin d’un NOUVEAU manuel.
En 1947, Lorie Tarshis, un économiste canadien
formé au keynésianisme à Cambridge
— en 1947, Lorie Tarshis a bien l’impression
que son manuel Elements of Economics est en
train de devenir LE MANUEL D’ÉCONOMIE KEYNÉSIEN
de référence.
Les ventes ont décollé.
Seulement, ça ne plaît pas à tout le monde.
Des mouvements anticommunistes accusent le
manuel d’être un cheval de troie pour les
idées marxistes.
Ils mettent la pression sur les universités.
Au bout d’un certain temps, l’autocensure
du monde académique tue le manuel.
Un autre économiste saisit alors l’opportunité
d’écrire LE MANUEL D’ÉCONOMIE de référence.
Les idées keynésiennes sont si influentes
qu’il est impossible de les ignorer.
Mais en leur donnant le monopole, on devient
la cible de groupes de pression.
Le défi consiste donc à enseigner ENSEMBLE
les idées keynésiennes et les idées classiques.
Paul Samuelson réussit son coup en réalisant
UNE SYNTHÈSE.
Son manuel L'Économique sorti en 1948 se
vend à des millions d’exemplaires.
Et du coup, Samuelson devient millionnaire,
grâce au manuel d’économie le plus vendu
de tous les temps.
Mais ce que révèle cette anecdote, c’est
qu’aux cours des Trente Glorieuses, les
idées de Keynes ne sont pas accueillies à
bras ouverts aux États-Unis.
Non, elles sont combattues — et même diabolisées.
Les keynésiens sont d’abord la cible de
la propagande conservatrice ;
puis ils sont même les victimes du maccarthysme,
cette chasse aux sorcières qui prend le nom
du sénateur américain responsable d’une
hystérie anticommuniste de plusieurs années.
Certains keynésiens font donc les frais d’une
paranoïa libérale et conservatrice.
Mais d’un autre côté, ce n’est pas à
100 % un délire paranoïaque.
Les idées de Keynes sont radicales, donc
elles attirent des socialistes depuis le début.
Dans les faits, beaucoup de keynésiens américains
sont en effet des sympathisants communistes
au cours des Trente Glorieuses.
Et comme on peut s’y attendre, dans le lot,
quelques uns ne se contentent pas d’une
adhésion intellectuelle :
ils vont jusqu’à agir clandestinement pour
l’URSS.
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.